welcome back to Facebook and uncensored
Professor Kathleen stock as due to
speaker Oxford University's 200 year old
Tibetan Society next month but she's
faced a furious backlash from students
who say her supposedly transphobic views
means she shouldn't be given a platform
which is the same academic who had to
quit her job as a lecturer at the
University of Sussex after being
targeted by activists for her views on
gender identity Oxford University's Vice
chancellor has defend his Stock's
appearance as a matter of Free Speech
but the university is braced for up to a
thousand protesters and counter
protesters to take action when she
appears at the end of the month the
Student Union is understood to have cut
ties with the debating Society so
there's a huge Rift now at the heart of
Oxford University it all begs the
question how exactly you're supposed to
have a debating Society if you don't
actually allow proper debate with people
whose opinions you don't like well join
me now is podcast host a comedian
Constantine kissing professor of
Sociology at Oxford University Dr
Michael Briggs and Oxford student and
trans rights activist rizz Posner well
welcome to all of you uh rizz you're
over there in Oxford
um let me start with you you've been on
the show before
um I don't get this the whole point of
getting universities you're supposed to
have open minds hear views you may not
like Channel manage them put your own
views forward evolve learn what's all
this censorship about
yeah I mean effectively this is students
exercising their own free speech right
like she has been platformed by this
institution students have consistently
said we don't think she should speak
here we don't want her hair because her
views are part of a broader hate
campaign and moral Panic that's really
damaging the lives of trans people so
students students have voted that they
don't want her here in their college
institutions in the student union and
now the University have overruled that
vote I also want to clarify something
here The Su the Student Union voted to
cut ties with the debating Society the
Oxford Union not over this but over an
extensive history of them um bullying
harassing and just having like General
bigotry racism within their within their
institution so it's not over this
nuanced issue it's about the history of
the but on the specific point about
Kathleen stock you tweeted this you've
got some Effie nerve Kathleen you've
brought your hatred into our community
and now you use the threats we receive
because of your actions to try to Garner
more sympathy for your victim narrative
Oxford doesn't want your bigotry here
and will make it known now I've studied
the Kathleen stock Saga I actually come
from Sussex so I had a vested interest
in my county and this University what is
it about her that is so hateful what has
she said or done that is actually so
wicked
yeah Kathleen has consistently uh well
so what she does is she's a academic
front basically for this broader
movement which she has uh endorsed she's
endorsed Percy Parker who has said
horrific things that I don't think would
be appropriate what is Kathleen's stock
hang on what is Kathleen stock herself
said or done to Warrant this treatment
yeah I don't know yeah I understand I
don't know if you've read her book first
you consistently misgenders people she
talks about whether like trans ideology
should exist whether a trans people
should be part of the lgbtq community
um now
her what she talks about is is part of a
massive campaign against trans people
and she wasn't kicked out of Warwick
University she left because she was
bummed that people didn't like what she
had to say because it happened
can I just yeah
here's my point
you see I have looked at what she said
she says many trans women are still
males with male genitalia many are
sexually attracted to females they
should not be in places where females
undress or sleep in an unrestricted way
self-id threatens a secure understanding
of the concept of lesbian and so on she
stands up for the sanctity of biological
sex
and I'm struggling to find out what is
so offensive about all this it seems to
me what's more offensive are young
students who think the biological sex is
a Movable Feast that can be denied and
that's the science is to be ignored and
that anyone can put their hand up and
say they're anything they like and they
have to be respected that I find more
offensive than anything Kathleen Stocker
said
so that's absolutely fine if you find
that offensive is the reality is as much
as she exercises her right to free
speech so do we the students have
consistently said as I've mentioned
before that they don't welcome her her
hair and specifically the tweet that you
quoted yeah but that's me honoring free
speeches that's the opposite of free
speech Yes what you're doing is
opinions you don't agree with my
argument is I agree with a lot of what
she says I don't get it what you're
doing is your business
as a group you're behaving like a bunch
of young fascists you want people only
people so who toe the line to your world
view and her worldview by the way could
you just let me know when I can come
back to those points all right well let
me let me come through now let me come
through okay Constantine this strikes me
as right to the heart of the malaise and
our Academia worldwide actually this
world view I don't like this person's
views even though they're not that
controversial at all in fact most people
would agree with them and yet they have
to be de-platformed abused Brandy bigots
blah blah blah this right here is the
heart of this of this problem and let me
answer the question that Riz didn't
answer when you asked her what Kathleen
has done that is so wrong is she's
blasphemed against this new religion
that says trans women are women and as
you say the vast majority of the public
don't agree with that and therefore
students have to then become little
fascist like you said and shut this down
because they can't tolerate hearing and
opinion that they don't like and so uh
to the extent that they have power
they're going to use it to bully people
into not speaking in places that they
can I'm grateful that the government
pushed through the the bill which now
means universities have to ensure that
free speech is respected there it's very
very important that these people don't
win because you can see their smug faces
as they do this no yeah and and they
enjoy the power and they enjoy
exercising over people and by the way
I've interviewed counseling on my show
trigonometry she's one of the sweetest
kindest more generous gentle people that
you will meet if she's hate full then
we're all hateful well this is the point
isn't it um Dr Breeze you've come here
from Oxford University what is going on
there because a lot of a lot of the
academic people there now seem to be
rising up against this and supporting
the concept of Free Speech but that's
causing a rift now in the University
what's really going on well I think it's
good that things have come to a head and
we finally can debate about whether
whether we could listen to the very mild
as Constantine said the very mild views
of Kathleen stock which really
represents the uh the majority of
British people now maybe not not the
majority of students but even the
minority of students have a right to
hear if they should they want to hear
Kathleen Stock's views and even people
who are opposed to her like like Riz
should go along out of the and and
listen and just decide what why exactly
what they disagree with
what this whole concept when I've when
I've taken part in the Oxford Union
which I've done and the Cambridge Union
and others I've always enjoyed it but
I've always gone there believing it was
my job to try and make people come
around to my way of thinking which was
an old debate I thought I was back at my
old prep school for the first time in 50
odd years uh the other day at the
weekend and I passed this old white
house where the head Masters wife used
to hold debating society when I was
about seven or eight
and that we were encouraged at that age
challenge other views listen to other
views formulate your own opinion and be
unafraid to change it if you hear things
which change your mind this is all just
gone out the window
so the problem is if you have a certain
Identity or if you have a certain view
then you can say I'm so vulnerable uh I
can't listen to any opposing views that
they even even now I kind of not listen
but even the very existence of those
other views being articulated somewhere
you know within the within a five mile
radius Catherine stock said anything
that you see which would justify this
kind of treatment no of course not no PS
just to the point you made about you
when you go and when I went to the
Oxford Union about trying to persuade
people and think about what would be the
circumstances in which you wouldn't want
to persuade people and you would want to
shut down people who disagree with you
the only circumstance in which you might
be tempted to do that is if you know
your arguments are rubbish yeah and that
is why these people or if you're living
in Russia China or North Korea right
where you would then call the secret
police and they would come and remove
the person with the offensive opinion
which was one that the government didn't
agree with or whatever and they would be
taken off to some Detention Center in
Siberia I mean this is this is where
we're heading this is what they don't
get these students is that once you
accept that you're allowed to do this to
people who are perfectly mainstream
opinions this is a slippery slope to do
to totalitarianism right quite
all right Riz we've can I respond to
that you can respond to that you're a
totalitarian Barbarian
so you've talked about uh fascism
fascism as a far right ideology about
suppressing stuff uh to be clear this
has been a consistent Democratic uh
students have made this together from
that point do you object to being called
right wing
yeah yeah absolutely I already mentioned
that because when we invited the
the president of Oxford University lgbtq
plus Society to come on the program he
replied I think he's a he
um this is Adi haran dimmer do you know
do you know that person
[Applause]
uh yeah and I'd actually like to talk
about that that person did not come on
your show because they have been subject
to this consistent property
that I've been talking about
hang on I'm going to finish my point
well
that wasn't the reason given by this
person who replied higher to my producer
nice to meet you we're reluctant to work
with right wing media so I'm not right
wing I've never been right wing uh
you're not right you object to being
called right wing I object to being cool
right wing so we found a point of
consensus
so the reason that uh other people don't
want to uh take up interviews like this
or be on platforms like this is because
of the hate campaigns
at least you have the gun should I just
respond to some of those points peers
well look here's my part I was paying
you I was actually paying you I was
paying you a compliment you do at least
come on and debate with me right yeah
because they don't want to hear someone
saying something they don't like
I'd really love to respond to that point
so you mentioned uh that the tweet that
I said in response to Kathleen now what
you didn't mention is that Kathleen was
responding to a tweet by Addie who you
previously mentioned uh publishing a
death threat that they received by one
of her fans that's why people don't want
to be on platforms like this now with
regards to a debate uh first of all I
don't believe that trans lives should be
a debate but that's not in question here
they weren't trying to put on a debate
this conversation before no one's
debating trans lives no one was debating
trans rights to fairness and equality
I've certainly never I've only ever
supported trans rights to fairness
equality but if you're gonna stand there
now on television and and say that you
believe what's happening in women's
sport for example is anything but
grotesquely unfair and unequal then say
so
if you genuinely believe it I think
what's grotesquely unfair and unequal is
the violence and hatred that trans
people are consistently facing in the
media in person in public and online as
well
wasn't my question is it fair that trans
athletes are now demolishing women born
with female biological bodies at women's
sport is that fair yes or no
this is a really boring point but I'm
happy to answer just give me a simple
yes or no that's not happening
all right absolutely allowed to it okay
it's not happening you're obviously not
reading the papers you're not watching
TV you are totally oblivious to the
reality of what's happening but I didn't
realize okay it's okay no problem
ignorance is bliss right good to see you
thank you very much um I mean again
because it's the mindset
doesn't even it wouldn't even consider
the possibility that what's happening in
sport and women's sport is is horrible
because she has no idea has no interest
only interested in the impact it's a
religion piece I've said this to you
before I'll say it again it's a
religious worldview whereby your beliefs
do not require evidence they're based on
a faith right and that's how these
people think so uh the reason I
mentioned the the Kathleen stock what
she's doing as all of us are doing is
right because she thinks she's entitled
to call this this woman Kathy's talk a
bigot and so on and so on um I want to
just quickly ask you about something
else because you're a comedian
John Cleese has warned that his life of
Brian's stage show based on the movie
shouldn't include a scene about a man
wanting to be a woman and having a baby
which is ironic given the subject matter
we've been just it was funny at the time
it's kind of ironic now
uh but he even John Cleese
feels compelled to perhaps remove that
because it may offend people the concept
of men of a joke about men having babies
but we've reached a point where yeah
there will be protests about that
because it's offensive isn't it amazing
because it looks like they're literally
quoting from 2023 conversations in the
satirical piece of satire becoming real
life and what it shows you I think most
of all how far we've come in this
delusion I totally agree because
actually not debris I mean that was
deemed to be humor at the time because
it was so ludicrous that nobody ever
assumed that would actually be a reality
but we've reached that point where
satire's coming true yes yes indeed but
I think though just to take up the point
about the the religion I mean the reason
why there's so much hate towards uh
Kathleen stock is because she's a
lesbian yeah because she's an apostate
so she's part of the LGBT community but
she's uh she's articulating a different
View and so therefore she has to be
she's much more threatening than than
most people would be I saw a community
called Freddie Quinn on morning TV Good
Morning Britain today and he made the
point there's a scene from that movie
with a guy with a lisp does that have to
go because it's offensive to people's
speech impediments there's a scene with
a character called incontinentia
buttocks is that offensive to people
with IBS it's the same with people with
big noses is that offensive to people
with big noses there's one about
blessing the cheese makers do we have to
reach out to a National Association of
Dairy Farmers to see if they're upset by
it and the truth is actually probably
yes because somebody somewhere would be
already getting the pitchforks out ready
to blow their gasket about all these
scenes being offensive until eventually
there is no Life of Brian that and
that's why I think all of us have to
just ignore these people being silly
which is what they're doing and say
you're allowed to be offended nothing
happens when you get offended nothing
changes and the world does not start
revolving well Ricky Gervais always says
yeah he has a right to say what he says
you have a right to be offended your
right to be offended doesn't over
overcome his own right to crack jokes uh
thank you both very much indeed I
appreciate should it